that i found
it's ah
so he talks about books in this
particular one he talks about russian
literature with reference to other world
literature and so forth
i really enjoy them
but i don't really understand
i like his voice
the quality of the sound the subject
matter
each one of his podcasts is about an
hour long i see here there are 53 of
them so far so this will keep me busy
for a long long time because i'll have
to listen to it many many times and
hopefully
get more of it as i go i didn't have my
microphone here get more of it as i go
along
uh ideally i would have transcripts
um
but the
voice quality content here is is more
attractive to me than much of the
material for which i have audio so i'm
going to stick with it if i could find
transcripts like for our english
podcasts
and some of the other language podcasts
we pay people
25 30 an hour that is per audio hour so
one hour would be 30
uh to transcribe them but these are
people who are well equipped and very
fast
um
if we can find someone to do that in
korean we would pay i would pay them
uh if i could get permission from mr kim
to use his
material at link and if we had
transcripts i would put them into our
library and share it with others
um
but it's quite exciting for me this is
kind of would be a real
goal to get to where i can understand
what he's saying now
i'm reading a lot reading you know
interesting things chosen ilbo for
example an article today about
uh
you know the
the anti-japanese feeling in korea
anti-korean feeling in japan quite a
you know
discouraging article about how
public opinion in both countries seems
to be hardening against
the other country you never know
journalists they write stuff because
they want to you know
look for sensational things so whether
that's true or not i have no idea uh but
at any rate that was the article lots of
words it was an interesting article and
of course as i read these
i don't have sound for them i don't have
the transcript for this it's not ideal
but the interest of the what i'm reading
or listening to is is for me more
attractive than other considerations
um i just can't continue listening to
a material that is just created for
learners it's after a certain point it's
just not
interesting enough i to me language
learning is it's got to be interesting
it can't be work
uh
uh of course initially yes it's work to
get to a point but then as soon as i got
a toehold on something that's
interesting that's what i want to run
with um
so what else uh
of course i watched the hockey game this
morning uh canada beat finland uh
although they played a very dumb game in
my opinion uh
always you know around the finished net
trying to score from three feet away at
any rate uh they won um
then i had an hour's conversation with
julian again and we talked again about
history some of these same issues i
talked to her about the article that i
had read on chosen elbow and so i was
able to use some of the vocabulary that
i had picked up there that i remembered
um
i did a bit of reading on my ipad and
when i worked out of course i listened
to
uh kim yomi hua here
um
as far as the assimil yesterday i had a
little film clip about my
i kind of got i made a big mistake i
thought that i for 23 euros i was
getting a complete set with two cds one
for remaining one for check
uh in fact all i got was the book
uh
the complete package with cds is like 63
euros which is to me almost it's like
around a hundred dollars i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna spend that when all i
really want is the audio uh i looked
through the books both of them are full
of grammar explanations and i have
grammar resources that i've downloaded
from the internet for romanian and czech
with tons of examples that are better
than
the sort of very explanation heavy but
and exercise heavy but no examples a
type of book that assimil offers i don't
understand why assimil is such a
so popular but i have to recognize that
different people study in different ways
for me i want content i want to listen i
want to get the language in me and then
so that on the other subject that i read
yes raised yesterday which was
i was going to attempt lucas sort of
translation method
i did it a little bit today in that when
i was reading an article that i had
downloaded from chosen elbow i would
save phrases
uh
in link creating a link therefore so the
phrase is now the term that i've saved
and then in the what we call the hint
field where you put the translation i
deleted whatever
um google translate had given me most of
it most of the time it's not that
accurate and i deliberately tried to
translate as as as you know as well as
possible the phrase that i had saved
and then i tried to translate it back
into korea
the problem there were two problems with
that one was that if i were to do that
it would take me forever to read through
this content and you know three hours is
all i have
uh to spend on korean and it's going to
be one hour at least of listening
and in the remaining hour or two
uh i want to be reading i want to be
saving words i want to be building my
vocabulary i want to be you know
consuming the language if i sit there
and and
try to translate all these little
phrases
you know it's just it's tremendously
time consuming so
that kind of demotivates me to do that
and the second thing is that i found
that after having done this for 10 or 15
phrases
phrases where there were words that i
didn't know
um
when i reread the text
i didn't i wasn't any better at those
words than
other words
so i didn't get the impression that it
helped me to retain anything
uh i think it will have would help me
to get better at using
korean
patterns when speaking so would improve
my speaking
but
i'm not that concerned about my speaking
i mean i am when i speak but once it's
over
i would rather have
a large vocabulary at the end of three
months so that i can
i can read what what educated koreans
have to say listen
to what people like this mr kim here
have to say
uh participate in a sort of an
interesting way and what koreans are
thinking and saying and and so forth
uh and if i do that i will end up
speaking okay
so i don't need to focus in right now
on on nailing down these patterns of the
language i can continue to stumble i do
some listening to patterns i do some
you know quick grammar review sort of
thing uh
the things that i have on my ipod are a
mixture of interesting material you know
authentic content if you want and some
basic patterns to
you know
familiarize myself with these with these
structures but
you know if i had 10 hours a day to
spend
then i might have a different strategy
but i have three hours
and i would rather spend those three
hours
basically consuming interesting content
building up my vocabulary i i notice now
already that i hear the language better
i read the language better it's less of
a strain to read
new text in korean and so i'm just going
to stay with with the strategy and
that's why by the way i've taken down my
hangul chart here i'm not going to write
the language i mean i've only got i've
got i mean i never write japanese i
lived in japan for nine years never had
need to write it i can type it on the
computer
um i can use my phonetic keyboard to
type the odd thing in russian but mostly
i listen and read and speak
so
one has to make decisions obviously if i
were living in korea and i was doing it
as an academic subject i might have a
different set of priorities but for my
goals i'm just going to focus on reading
listening speaking building up my
vocabulary so
this i'm in the second month here of the
three month challenge i'm going to
maintain this focus on input speak maybe
two hours a week
when i get into the third month i'm
hoping to step up my weekly speaking
so that's
perhaps there were some other things
that i was going to say but i don't
remember what they are and i ranted here
a bit too long anyway